we saw what happened with the revelation
of Maria you know this is the Antichrist
so I said to him you know these
Palestinians are Muslims and Christians
see Ellie went under cover as a priest
for a day dressed in a robe he walked
through the old city with Franciscan
father Alberto in the first five minutes
he was spat at five times by Orthodox
Jewish Israelis according to the New
Testament Christian Zionism is utter
blasphemy people who worship Idol such
as yourself when there is a
Sanhedrin
to kill us yes okay that's what the tour
so we know how the Jewish people feel
about Christians yes James White J White
that the Modern Nation of Israel 1948
onward Israel is anywhere in scripture
so Ben gavier used to have a picture of
baroo Goldstein hanging in his living
room wow Goldstein who in 1994 attacked
the ibrahimi MOs and Hebron so Zionism
is a betrayal of the Old Testament God
and a betrayal of the New Testament God
both of them anything Israel says is
absolutely well of course you realize
this is not a Christian Nation these are
not Christian people they're primarily
secular Zionism as deployed by Israel is
radical Judaism
alhamdulillah greetings of Peace welcome
to the de sham Med your host my next
guest Dr Ali AA Dr Ali ATA is a PhD
scholar of the Bible and Bible
interpretation he's an expert in the
languages of the Bible Hebrew and Greek
so we wanted to bring on an expert to
help us understand this topic that we're
going to be discussing in the light of
what's happening in Palestine is there
such a thing as radical Judaism what's
this term hen if I'm pronouncing it
right mvah 528 amongst other things so
let's get right into this topic with my
next guest Dr Ali this
the love
you're when I was ready to talk about it
I would only talk to I was explaining
how much respect I have for the faith of
Islam alaykum waum brother Eddie how are
you alhamdulillah how are you doing
alhamdulillah thank you it's an honor to
be here thank you it's an honor to have
you with us you were saying something uh
recently I saw a clip uh you were saying
usually when you're given a presentation
and you can explain you were talking and
giving a presentation about Islam and
then somebody started to drill you about
Jihad was it yeah that's you know after
911 uh we do it all this you know
Interfaith work going to churches
community centers uh and uh yeah that
that was probably the most popular
question what's Jihad what's Jihad and
you know we'd answer questions and it
feels like we were constantly on the
defensive uh and uh and so I explained
what Jihad was and this this Christian
guy you know he kept pushing back and he
wanted to debate me and he was
disagreeing with me so I said to him
what's right and he said well I've never
heard of that I said that's interesting
because that's uh it's a uh it's a war
policy in the Bible it's all over the
Bible how do you pronounce that again so
it's h m but it's like a hard
gut
uh yeah yeah and I'll explain what it is
well basically it's it's total
Annihilation total
extermination genocide if you will
that's mentioned many times in the Bible
uh and there really is no sort of um
demand for an explanation when it comes
to things like this but we're always
sort of on the back foot defending
ourselves you said there is no demand
for an explanation to this but we're
always demanded to explain Jihad and
some of the other some of the other
verses that many of the islamophobe the
haen industry they pick and choose pick
and put out out of context and what not
I just want to make this disclaimer
because I as Muslims we are people who
are commanded to be just to be fair so
we don't play that game like the
islamophobic industry like they'll take
a small segment or a fringe element and
they'll give a fringe interpretation to
certain verses and then they'll try to
the consensus will be on one side but
then they'll try to push the majority of
people to have that uh de or Isis
interpretation of Islam and tried to you
know actually breeding they'll be on the
side of almost like the the extremists
on one end and then they'll put aside
all of the the mainstream and and the
the whole consensus of scholarship no no
no so here if they're if they're rabbis
and others who want to come we want be
on the side of people are promoting
Peace So if you have other would you say
it's safe to say if there's rabbis and
others who come and say no this is not
our teaching we'll be on the side with
them to go ahead and help to get these
people out of this extreme way of
thinking so we can actually have some
tolerance and peace huh of course I mean
that's that's the uh that's part of what
I'm going to explain today is how do how
do uh traditional authorities amongst
the Jews how do they interpret these
verses in the Bible what is their
application today because it's very
different than what the zionists are
doing in in so-called Israel Bingo
beautiful so please start us off thank
you so much yeah so radical Judaism
right this is a term that you know we
should uh start using I think because
that's what we're seeing right now
radical Judaism is a dysfunctional
marriage basically an holy Union uh
between uh modern Orthodox Judaism and
Zionism uh radical Judaism is a uh
perversion of traditional Judaism uh so
like I said brother Eddie in my view
it's very very important for Muslims uh
to have a more comprehensive theological
understanding of the present situation
in Palestine we really need to step up
our before before you keep going I think
a real important point I'm marking this
down so you you put two ingredients
together and you put Zionism in there
and that then with those ingredients
then you C then you came up with radical
J Judaism so if someone do that repeat
that please yeah modern Orthodox Judaism
modern Orthodox with Zionism with
Zionism so that's the ingredient there
with Zionism equals radicalism okay go
Ahad yeah yeah exactly thank you so much
yeah so first of all what what is
Zionism uh so this is a very common
question so broadly speaking Zionism is
a uh a modern nationalistic movement
right aimed at reestablishing a Jewish
homeland right so the creation of a
Jewish ethnos State and this was born in
Europe I mean European anti-Semitism
gave birth to Zionism uh historically um
Jews had a horrible time in in Christian
dominated countries in Europe this is
just a a plain fact you know there were
pgms Exiles um massacres blood lials the
plague was blamed on them at one point I
mean all of this culminated uh in the
Holocaust uh the Jewish experience in in
the Muslim world was very different
however if you look at like Muslim Spain
Muslim North Africa Muslim Palestine I
mean generally there was peace
prosperity tolerance there was
Brotherhood there was trust um not to
mention incredible scholarship Jewish uh
Systematic Theology was born in Muslim
lands uh myodes uh the great philosopher
the great Theologian he wrote an Arabic
Sadia gion the first uh you know um
discursive Theologian he wrote in Arabic
the the so-called father of Zionism was
named Theodore herel right Theodore
Herzel this is the the prophet you can
say that the zionists or the
radical Judaism people radical J they
follow this Prophet they don't it don't
seem like they follow Moses doesn't seem
like yeah exactly and it ironically he
was an ethnically jewish atheist he was
that was another thing I was going to
ask you is it confirmed he was actually
oh my God he was an atheist yeah he was
an atheist yeah I always point out the
irony here right Theodore means gift of
God right how does it so someone who now
is the prophet of Zionism and now he's
saying we're the chosen people of God
but he's an
atheist yeah strange very strange yeah
and so and so herel was actually
seriously considering Argentina as being
the Jewish homeland because he did not
have this romantic attachment to
Palestine but and this and this is to
your question as Zionist idea were sort
of in the air as it were in Europe Many
religious Jews who are now considering
the Zionist project did have a strong
attachment to Palestine and so Zionist
ideas were eventually
appropriated by Orthodox thinkers and
given a religiously sanctioned makeover
so to put it bluntly Zionism is a
hijacking of Orthodox traditional
Judaism okay the vast majority of of
Jewish thinkers before World War II were
vehemently anti- Zionist before the
Advent of Zionism for hundreds and
hundreds and hundreds of years Jews the
world over believed based upon explicit
texts in the Tanakh the Hebrew Bible
okay they believed that their Exile from
the holy land was justified that it was
divinely decreed due to their
Disobedience Jewish Disobedience right
in other words the holy land or the
promised land was given on a condition
so this is extremely important it was
conditional obey God or else the land
will reject you and thrust you out right
that is to say God will thrust you out
so no one other than God uh by means of
the Messiah can initiate a return to the
land right this is what all the Jews
believed this is traditional Judaism any
attempt to reestablish the land through
military means was viewed as Rebellion
against God I me if you just read for
example Deuteronomy so the fifth book of
the T Torah the Torah as we have it
today it's called Deuteronomy this is
chapter 28 uh verse 63 and 64 okay in
Hebrew this is called seim and this is
what it says in the English translation
and it shall come to pass just as it
pleased the Lord to make you prosper and
increase in number so it will please him
to ruin and destroy you you will be
uprooted from the land you're entering
to
possess right this is a threat this is
called a in Arabic God is issuing a
threat to B is to the Ben is you obey me
or I will take you out of this land in
1889 a a prominent Orthodox Rabbi named
Rabbi Joseph Kim sonnenfeld Rabbi
sonnenfeld this is what he had to say
about Herzel and his ideology this is a
famous quote from Rabbi sonnenfeld I'll
just read it here he says he says with
regards to the Zionist uh what I um what
uh what am what am I to say what am I to
speak there is great dismay also in the
holy land that these evil men who who
deny the unique one of the world and His
holy Tor have proclaimed with so much
publicity publicity that it is in their
power to Hassen Redemption for the
people of Israel and to gather the
dispersed from all the ends of the Earth
they have also asserted their view that
the whole difference and distinction
between Israel and the Nations lies in
nationalism blood and race and that the
faith and the religion are Superfluous
do hersel comes not from the Lord but
from the side of pollution wow that's
Rabbi son now these are the real
practicing Jews these are the this is
this is this is real Judaism they
condemning now they're condemning this
whole movement now this Zionism that
hijacked Judaism exactly he's condemning
Theodore hsel who's not doesn't even
believe in God his principles are going
to be appropriated by Orthodox elements
what you're saying is identical to when
I had I don't know if you heard of Rabbi
Weiss I've had another other Rabbi on
Rabbi Shapiro and other they saying
exactly what you're saying yeah Orthodox
rabbis same thing of course this this is
this is the Orthodox understanding for
centuries there's another verse in
Deuteronomy 21 to30 so Moses is speaking
to the children of Israel and he says
for I know that after my death you will
utterly corrupt yourselves and turn
aside from the way which I have
commanded you that's what you were
talking about earlier Eddie they're
turning away from Moses they're
following another prophet and then he
continues and evil will befall you in
the latter
days because you will do evil in the
sight of the Lord to provoke him to
anger through the works of your hands
Deuteronomy 31 uh30 right they will do
evil in the latter days so yeah I think
it's very important to draw a
distinction between traditional Judaism
and Zionist Judaism also known as
radical Judaism of course uh even today
there are many Orthodox and conservative
Jews religious Jews who vehemently
oppose Zionism on both theological and
moral grounds they accuse zionists of
exactly what we said hijacking Judaism
they have a motto they say yahudi in
Hebrew which means a Jew is not a
Zionist so they actually
anathematize Zionist Jews they make took
fear of them can you can you equate like
so people can better understand is like
for Christians if the KKK hijacked
Christianity and they took over and they
were ruling right now exactly or if you
had D you know this Isis they took over
and they were the majority
the same example here same thing yeah
imagine one of these violent groups
these these terroristic groups they
basically took over and they're and
they're running a government you know
they're in power that's what's happening
here's the dangerous thing really
dangerous because we anytime that small
small group comes up the Muslim
scholarship the Muslims condemn them
they you know get rid of them whatnot
and here it's like people are now
fueling them it's very very very strange
that's a strange thing are promoting
this yeah promoting exactly yeah so yeah
but traditional Jews would say no
there's a fundamental incompatibility
between Judaism and Zionism so one such
organization is called notur Carta notur
Carta International uh and their leaders
are aligned with the Muslim Community on
the issue of Palestine they even attend
major like conventions and events they
go to like the RIS and Toronto they go
to isna I mean do we agree with
everything that they say no of course
not they're Jews and were Muslims right
so so this is what happened essentially
Zionist ideas were uh adopted and
appropriated by many Orthodox leaders
starting in the early 20th century uh
and then these ideas have grown as you
said in popularity among their segment
uh and so Zionism became a reformed
movement within modern Orthodoxy and
this is what I'm calling radical Judaism
why is it radical because Zionist Jews
interpret and apply certain passages in
the Torah
um certain mitzvot or Commandments in
the Torah in extremely violent ways so
these are interpretations and
applications that fly right into the
face uh of the traditional
understandings of the major rabinal
authorities um so let me let me give the
viewers uh some some brief history then
please just for the sake of context so
in in 1917 right the British empire
under General Allenby conquered
Palestine in and promised to give it to
the Jews okay to be their Homeland this
is called the Balor declaration uh most
people know about this uh they wanted to
create a national home for the Jewish
people to quote it exactly Arthur balfor
was the foreign secretary under David
Lloyd George who was the Prime Minister
so so Jews from all over Europe began
pouring into Palestine British mandate
Palestine which obviously caused tension
between the indigenous Arabs and the
newly arrived European Jews uh in the
1920s and 30s various Jewish militia
groups sprang up in Palestine groups
like hagana and iron all right these
groups are terrorist groups I mean let's
call it like it is these groups would
commit political violence
atrocities uh and absolutely terrorize
the Palestinians uh at some point in the
1940s the British wanted to restrict
Jewish immigration to Palestine of
course iron didn't like that so they
blew up the King David Hotel wow 1946
that was the headquarters of the British
they killed Muslims Jews Christians men
women and children and here's something
interesting manim Bean the former prime
minister um of Israel was the was the
former head of the eron um and after the
eron after 1948 um after Israel was
established uh the Aron became the IDF
right uh so it's very interesting
history so in 1947 then the British they
they kind of just threw their hands up
and left Palestine I mean they left
Palestine to the United Nations it's a
un problem now so the UN partitioned
Palestine uh you know you know when like
European colonizers left the Muslim
countries in North Africa the people of
those countries the algerians the
tunisians ETC they resumed control of
their own land of course it was their
countries but in Palestine there was a
partition the Jews constituted about
onethird of the population uh most of
them newly arrived uh yet they were
offered 56% of Palestine okay the Arabs
who were the majority and had lived
there for centuries were offered 44% and
neither Group found this favorable I
mean the Israelis they don't want an
Arab majority they want a Jewish ethn
state right an Arab majority totally
contradicts this now starting in March
1948 uh Israeli militia groups you know
these these terrorist factions they put
something called plit into action so
people should look this up PL d d a l e
t that's that's the letter Dal in in
Hebrew uhhuh right plan doet and I
highly recommend reading uh this book by
Elon Pape all right um very popular book
now Elon Pape now he's a Jewish also
Israeli historian correct he's he's an
Israeli journalist and historian he
wrote this fantastic book The that's
that's an important point because this
is not coming from the Muslim
perspective this is actually somebody
who's Jewish Israel historian bringing
these he is the the the ethnic cleansing
of Palestine and he describes what they
did what did Clan doet do it displaced
750,000 Palestinians it forced them to
leave Palestine or forced them into Gaza
which of course became a huge open air
concentration camp 500 Villages were
destroyed uh and there were many reports
of multiple massacr indiscriminate
killing of men women and children for
example the DAR yasim uh Massacre there
was a massacre at hia there was a Massac
at Jaffa uh Israel declared itself a
state on May 14th 1948 and then the UN
formerly recognized Israel on May 11th
1949 uh and the Palestinian territories
until this day continue to be under
occupation uh and continue to shrink and
Palestinians continue to live as second
class citizens uh in their own country
you know interestingly in 1994 an
Israeli terrorist okay and Jewish
radical named baruk Goldstein just
Google Baro Goldstein I mean we forget
about these people but we shouldn't
forget history he massacred 29
Palestinians who are worshiping at
I entered the mosque waited for
worshippers to kneel down in prayer and
then started shooting bar Goldstein
killed 29 people and injured more than
120 one witness described how there were
bodies and blood everywhere I think that
uh his act brought a lot of uh security
to the Jewish people here Inon
goldstein's grave is often visited by
supporters and his Tombstone reads he
gave his life for the people of Israel
its Torah and land under the pretext of
securing the settlers who lived in the
old city and preventing more violence
the Israeli Army imposed a twoe curfew
on all of hebron's Palestinians it made
the area around the ibraimi mosque
permanently off limits to everyone
except settlers and foreign tourists the
old city is now cut off from the rest of
Hebron by dozens of Israeli checkpoints
basically the settlers won in Hebron in
alal they were worshiping this this is
in the occupied West Bank this happened
at Salat F in Ramadan right 29 men women
men women and children killed another
130 injured Goldstein was born in
Brooklyn and he moved to Israel 1983
after becoming radicalized he was a
member of a radical Jewish movement
called The kak Party The kak Party very
guttural founded in
1971 this party was banned in Israel in
1994 and declared a terrorist
organization and while the majority of
Israelis today condemn Goldstein for
being the terrorist that he was a
minority of Jewish radicals praise him
they continue to make an annual
pilgrimage to his gravite right someone
who killed prostrating children it
actually says on his tomb this is what
it says it's chiseled on his tomb it
says the Reverend Dr bar Kel Goldstein
son of Israel he gave his soul for the
sake of the people of Israel the Torah
and the land his hands are clean and his
heart is
good disturbingly goldstein's ideology
has recently made a comeback
uh there is this farri party in Israel
it's called yudit in Hebrew yudit means
Jewish power and in 2022 the leader of
this party itamar Ben gavier became
minister of National Security under
Netanyahu so benir used to have a
picture of baruk Goldstein hanging in
his living room wow in
2017 benir was convicted of incitement
to terrorism his attempts at joining the
right-wing Kess list under former prime
minister navali Bennett were initially
quashed because of his long-standing
support for convicted terrorist baruk
Goldstein who in 1994 attacked the
ibrahimi mosque in Hebron killing 29
Muslim worshippers benav famously hung a
photo of Goldstein in his living room
which he eventually removed to improve
his chances of forming political
alliances and became a canescent member
in
Goldstein is his hero and now this is a
person that is in the cabinet now he's
in the cabinet he's in the cabinet yeah
he's part of the the parliament of uh
the people who are in power right now
wow his his ideology goldstein's
ideology is now the mainstream in
Israel okay this is very disturbing now
I also want to say a few things about uh
the idea of a Christian Zionist okay so
these these two words should never be an
opposition to each other it's a total
oxymoron Christian Zionism Christian
totally oxymoron oxymoron like like you
know jumbo shrimp four-sided triangle
right this whole concept of a Christian
Zionist is absolutely mindboggling and
I'll tell you why I'll tell you why it
boggles the mind so so part and parcel
to the Zionist project from a Jewish
religious standpoint is the construction
of the Third Temple right on the Temple
mount in Jerusalem of course the the
first temple was was built by Solomon
suan around 1,000 BCE it was destroyed
by the Babylonians in 586 under
Nebuchadnezzar the second temple was
built around 515 dce so this is when the
Israelites returned from Babylonian
captivity they were released by cus and
then the second temple was destroyed in
70 of the Common Era by the Romans okay
under General Titus uh now uh Jewish
zionists want to build the Third Temple
now it is clearly unambiguously
unequivocally against the teachings of
the New Testament for a Christian to
support the construction of a third
Temple in Jerusalem for a Christian to
do this is to commit clearcut blasphemy
repeat that again repeat that again this
is very very important so you said that
it is totally against it is absolute
blasphemy blasphemy for for a Christian
isur for a Christian to support the
building of a third temple in Jerusalem
according to the New Testament okay and
yet there are millions upon Millions of
Christians zus around the world they
donate millions of dollars to something
called the temple Institute in Jerusalem
you know in fact the vast majority of
zionists are actually Christians they're
not they're not even Jewish okay so a
Christian said a Christian who's been
programmed now and with this uh what I
call it this Force they're trying to
force prop prophecy instead of letting
to come naturally they're trying to
force this and the Christian like who's
been he been programmed by this uh he
says how explain to me how is that
blasphemy in religion well in the New
Testament Jesus himself is the new
Temple okay so the Gospel of John begins
with the prologue it's called the him to
the logos in the beginning was the word
the word was with God the Word was God
and then it continues it says and the
word became flesh and dwelt Among Us
right and interestingly the Greek I can
read the Greek
hereos so uh the verb here esos in Greek
it comes from the the Greek word SK
which means a tent or a canopy so you
see the Old Testament the what's known
as the cavod right the presence of God
it dwell in the tent of meeting this is
called the mishan in Hebrew this is the
Tabernacle sort of the portable you know
tent in the Wilderness at the time of
Moses and Joshua Moses would go inside
the Tabernacle to speak to God of course
this indwelling of God was figurative it
wasn't it wasn't literal so this tent
was the Prototype of the first temple
built by Solomon 400 years later so the
temple honorific is called the house of
God right Bethel beah again in this kind
of figurative sense the the temple house
God's spirit in this figurative sense
but what does John say in the prologue
the word became flesh and tented himself
Among Us in other words Jesus is the new
mishan the new tent that houses the
cavod the presence of God in the very
next chapter John Chapter 2 we read that
the Jews said to Jesus what sign can you
give us and Jesus says this is the
Johann and Jesus the New Testament Jesus
this is not Isa this is the Jesus of
Christian scripture Jesus of the
Christian scripture says destroy this
Temple and I'll raise it up in three
days and then the Jews said What it Took
46 years to build this Temple you're
going to raise it in three days right
and then the author John says but he
spoke of the Temple of his body you see
so the Hebrew word for temple is heal it
also means body the New Testament Jesus
is saying that he is the new Temple for
Christians to support the construction
of a third Temple in Jerusalem is to
deny the New Testament Jesus Jesus
replaces the temple according to the New
Testament and I and I've had I just
recently had a pastor on he was uh with
the CNN anchor he was on CBN he was uh
he's with um he's somebody who's also I
asked him this question how did this
happen this Christian Zionism and he
took me back uh with the scoffield Bible
even before that John Nelson
and then from there they put these
teachings what was a con man this con
man who was in jail this Cyrus scoffield
and then he put all these John Derby's
teachings into the Bible things of their
way out there extreme teachings from
Christianity he put them in and it was
funded actually he talks about how this
was funded by Zionism and they put these
interpretations in the footnotes you
know about this yeah exactly the
scoffield Bible is notorious so this is
something that's quite recent but you
know then you had doctor you just had so
this is one pastor this is not just us
talking about I just want to hit this
point you had uh just recently also you
probably know him uh he's one of the
leading uh Christian Scholars Bible
scholars here in America Dr White James
White James White he just came out and
he's also saying EXA exactly almost what
you're saying I'm sorry but I have never
seen anyone including my dear brother
Michael Brown present any kind of
meaningful biblical
argument that the Modern Nation of
Israel 19 48 onward Israel is anywhere
in scripture sorry I I know it's
extremely
popular but it
just you can't defend it biblically that
this Christian Zionism is totally uh
antithetical to um Christianity I've
seen this come and go I've seen people
saying you just need to look to what the
Bible says to be able to discern what's
happening in the Middle East and the 10
nations of the European Union is the
10he headed beast and that means this is
going to happen
yeah yeah been there done that got the
t-shirt and have come to realize that's
a really foolish way of doing ex Jesus
this attitude is dangerous it's
dangerous yeah somebody pulled the wool
over the eyes of the Christians because
you know I was going to say what what
can the average Christian do he doesn't
know it's actually happening behind the
scenes of his Bible he goes to the
bookstore he picks up a Bible he starts
reading it and so now we have Zionist
Jews rebelling against God's decree of
Exile and we have Christian uh zionists
rebelling against God's pronouncement
that he is the Temple of course they
believe that Jesus uh is the temple uh
there's a sign uh in in Israel the
modern Israelis put it up right right uh
near the Temple mount it says the divine
presence never moves from the Western
Wall okay um which is very interesting
because no Christian on Earth if he
wants to follow the teachings of the New
Testament can ever agree with such a
statement it is absolute blasphemous
even the the Catholic catechism it says
Christ is the true temple of God the
place where his glory dwells so
Christian Zionism is a betrayal of the
New Testament Jesus Christian Zionism uh
so Zionism is a betrayal of the Old
Testament God and a betrayal of the New
Testament God both of them anything
Israel says is absolutely well of course
it's
like you realize this is not a Christian
Nation these are not Christian people
they're primarily
secular and so they now have religious
infallibility because of
your really really really modern
eschatology this is this is not sound
biblical reasoning at all it's dangerous
it's scary you know then here's another
thing in John and I mentioned this uh as
well recently in another um lecture that
uh the author of The Gospel of John
who's Anonymous he actually moved the
day of the crucifixion one day ahead
right so in the in the Matthew Mark and
Luke the synoptic gospel El Jesus is
crucified on the day of Passover but
John actually moved it to the previous
day the day of the preparation of the
Passover so another words there's a the
first problem here is there's a clear
contradiction in the gospels I mean
certainly Jesus was not crucified twice
this is an
irreconcilable contradiction I mean from
our perspective he wasn't even crucified
once right but that's that's a different
uh podcast but but why did John do that
why did John move up the day of the
crucifixion well this is because uh the
Lambs in the temple were being
slaughtered at that time now in the
Gospel of John only in John do we find
that a Roman Centurion actually impaled
the side of Jesus when he was uh when he
was on the cross and it says from which
came forth blood and water right so
what's the significance of that well on
the on that on that very day at that
very moment the Lambs were being
slaughtered for the Passover in the
temple right the priests of the temple
the kohanim they would open a side gate
in the temple and they would wash out
the blood with water blood and water
would G gush forth from the side of the
temple so you see what John is doing
here in his gospel he's depicting Jesus
as both lamb and Temple Jesus is the new
Temple according to the New Testament
Christian Zionism is utter blasphemy do
do they have also from here they're
shipping out calves like they're making
red calves have you heard of this and
they're trying shipping them here from
America down there this is also to try
to fulfill that prophecy yeah so in
order for the uh the temple rituals to
be purified order in order for the
kohanim the priests to be purified in
order to actually work in the temple
they need to purify um the water of the
temple with the ashes of a
three-year-old perfect red hepher this
is mentioned I believe in The Book of
Leviticus uh so uh currently there's I
think there's four or five of them that
are actually brought into Israel they I
think they're actually from texus and
they may have been genetically modified
yeah yes Allah so I think there as far
as I know the last time I checked in
October uh I think all five of them are
still blemish free you know so these are
like Frankenstein prophecies they're
trying to make Frankenstein yeah yeah I
mean they're I mean they're gonna
they're going to push hard to make these
things you know to self fulfill these
things right yeah it's very interesting
uh but there there's another verse in um
uh and and Muslims should make a note of
this in first John 2:22 so this is the
first Epistle of John this is not the
Gospel of John although it's sort of the
same you know ology 1 John 2:22 the
author says who is the liar but he who
denies that Jesus is the Christ and then
it goes on to saying the Greek anti this
is the Antichrist the one who denies
that Jesus is the Messiah is the
Antichrist this is the New Testament
this is the teaching of the New
Testament this is not my opinion you
know this is not what the Quran says
this is not what the Hadith says this is
a new testament and Eddie I'll tell you
a true story whoever repeat that again
before you go whoever whoever Den that
Jesus is the Messiah we don't deny Jesus
is the Messiah yeah exactly we believe
he's the Messiah exactly so I'll tell
you a funny story I was in a coffee shop
years ago and uh I was I was um I was
studying for I was doing something with
my dissertation so I had a Quran in a
Bible on my table uh and this was
something like crazy early in the
morning like 6:30 in the morning or
something like that and there's a long
line forming behind me and there was a a
gentleman behind me with his wife uh who
looks over my shoulder and says oh you
have these two books on your table I
said yeah he said one of them is from
God and one is from Satan wow so so I
said oh okay I mean it's kind of early
in the morning for this but you know
well tell let's talk and he says oh
which one's from God and He pointed to
the Bible and I said okay so this one's
from Satan the quran's from Satan he
said yeah and so why do you say that and
he said well you know the Bible teaches
that those who oppose Israel will be ACC
cursed right anyone who opposes Israel
will be cursed you know this kind of
skill field Bible line uh and so he he
goes on to say these Palestinians in
Israel right right uh they're all
antichrists and he used that word
Antichrist so I said to him the
Palestinians are Antichrist and he said
yes uh and I said does the bible say
that the Palestinians are Antichrist
does he actually use that word he says
no but whoever opposes Israel is a
cursed uh so I said well you know the
New Testament does mention the
Antichrist let's read 1 John 2:22 and I
read this verse whoever does not you
know uh um the one who denies that Jesus
is the Messiah you know this is the
Antichrist so I said to him you know
these Palestinians are Muslims and
Christians you know who they believe the
Messiah is is Jesus Christ is Jesus of
Nazareth peace be upon him but these
Israelis don't so who's the Antichrist
and I remember he became so enraged I
mean he literally tried to physically
attack me his wife had to hold him back
but you're telling the truth the truth
shall set you free exactly you're
bringing evidence that's the Gospel of
John too yeah but it seems like people
don't want to be led to the truth they
want to stick in their bubble and
believe these fake prophecies and these
fake interpretations well that's what it
is it's called cognitive dissonance
right so when your beliefs are suddenly
falsified and you have no rejoinder you
know you just you have to you don't know
what to some people they fight some
people they fly right because they don't
know what to do with that tension they
don't know how to resolve that tension
so the rap so the Rapture this whole
thing that also is connected to that
this is a fake teaching right this is
false the Rapture is a later teaching
it's based on something Paul says we're
going to be caught up in the clouds with
the Lord yeah but it seems like Paul is
saying they're sort of going to levitate
and sort of meet Jesus as he's
descending and then descend down to
earth uh you know this idea that you're
going to sort of just disappear this is
a later teaching completely this was
this pastor was telling me the same
thing this is another thing that they
use this was in the scoffield reference
they added this and this this is
something that that's also there's
there's this whole series called Left
Behind this very popular Evangelical set
of books and they made movies and I mean
it's all based on this basically it's a
bid in in
Christianity U but yeah what the Jews
are no longer chosen people this to say
that they are is is also a bid this is a
clear teaching in the New Testament the
New Testament advances what's known as
replacement theology okay it's also
called covenantal supersessionism so
what does that mean so supersessionism
is this idea that the Christian church
has superseded the nation of Israel as
God's covenant people you know it's very
clear so there's that verse in Genesis
123 so Christian zionists they love this
verse Genesis 123 where God says to
Abraham and I will bless them that bless
you and curse them that curse you right
so they take this to mean this is this
is a clear one of very very important
Christian Zionist teachings here this
ver we see a lot of politicians and
they'll put this repeat that one again
this is their bread and butter genis 12
verse3 I will bless them that bless you
and curse them that curse you right and
so they take this to mean that that they
have to bless Abraham and his chosen
seed the Israelites or else God will
curse them so in their minds it follows
them that if they don't bless and
support the modern state of Israel then
God won't bless them so this is what
they say and you know it's really
interesting about this is that in order
for a Christian to immigrate to Israel
he must renounce Christianity Israel
will gladly accept his Christian money
with a big smile but in order for a
Christian to move to Israel that
Christian has to admit that Jesus of
Nazareth peace be upon him as was a
false prophet and a Pudo Messiah W he's
got a apostate become apostate now in
order to move to Israel yeah but this is
what the Christian Scientists are saying
we have a religious duty to love and
support Israel this is totally
contradictory to the new test just read
Paul of Tarsus so Paul is the principal
author of the New Testament 13 of the 27
books of the New Testament are explicit
ly attributed to Paul and Paul is a
supersessionist to his core and listen
to what Paul says this is Galatians 3:16
okay and here Paul is actually
commenting upon God's covenant with
Abraham in Genesis so this is what he
says he says the promises were spoken to
Abraham and to his seed and of course
here the Christian Zionist will say Amen
but Paul continues scripture does not
say and to his seeds plural meaning many
people but and to your seed singular
meaning one person who is Christ so
according to Paul okay God in Genesis
was only referring to Jesus Christ as
being Abraham's seed only Jesus is
blessed not the Israelites and certainly
not the modern state of Israel now Paul
goes on to say in Galatians chapter 3:
28 there is neither Jew or Greek uh
there is neither Bond nor free there is
neither male or female for you are all
one in Christ Jesus if you belong to
Christ then you are Abraham's seed
Galatians 3:29 if you belong to Christ
then this is called a conditional
statement and in the Greek it's
conditional a spelled Epsilon Iota in
Greek is a conditional particle if you
belong to Christ he says to
Abraham then you are considered Abraham
SE so Christians are the new chosen
people according to the New Testament
you are only Chosen and blessed if you
believe in Jesus I mean of course that's
what Paul is saying Paul is a Christian
um if you read 1 Thessalonians chapter
2:14 this is written by Paul this is his
earliest letter listen to what Paul says
in 1 Thessalonians 2:4 and 15 I'll just
quote it here for you brothers and
sisters became imitators of God's
churches in Judea which are now in
Christ Jesus you suffered uh you
suffered from your own people the same
things those churches suffered from the
Jews who both killed the Lord Jesus and
the prophets and drove us out and
displeased God and oppose all
mankind this is Paul describing the Jews
this is not the Quran this is not you
know some Hadith I no I'm sure that
Christian apologists can defend these
things but why is it that we don't hear
these defenses ever they just pretend
like these verses don't exist we never
hear about them but we have to do our
homework you know are the Jews who wrote
The talmud Still Chosen and beloved by
God according to the Christians
according to Christian zus are are the
Jews still the apple of God's eye who
cursed and slandered Jesus and his
mother Mary in the talmood there's a
book by Peter schaer this is published
by Princeton University it's called
Jesus in the talmood just read what the
rabbis or don't read you know I wouldn't
read it actually just take my word for
it it'll make make your skin crawl you
won't believe it you know the the
analogy I use is if you went into like a
closet for 24 hours and just sat there
like this for 24 hours and thought of
the most depraved and demeaning and
dehumanizing thing you can possibly say
about another human being it won't even
to what the rabbi said about Jesus and
Mary in the in the talmo it's one thing
it's one thing now coming from you now
they say you're bias you're Muslim but
if we can would you mind if we can show
an actual Rabbi talking about what
you're saying yeah go go for it yeah
sure why is not dreams of all kinds
of that had a dream all of
revelation we saw what happened with the
revelation of
Maria 2,000 years of suffering came to
the World Christian Inquisition Spain
Portugal Holocaust PS from a dream of a
prostitute who cheated on a husband
that's it from that
two billion people today follow this
Idol named
JC why one dream a lot of Dreams there's
people that live in illusion even when
they're awake not when they sleep when
they awake they man I I had an verion
when he he was um talking about uh Mary
the Mother
medium about Jesus's mother yeah the
Quran tells us we be
the Quran tells us these things the
Quran is uh you know it's uh it's a
revelation it tells us and this is like
sort of specialized knowledge I mean how
did the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam of course he didn't write the
Quran but you know they they say he he
wrote the Quran or he he came up with
the verses of the Quran how did he know
something like this something so
specialized that you can only get from
sort of oral tradition or from the
talmud but the Quran tells us uh for
their disbelief in that they uttered
something monstrous about about Mary you
know he's this is this is what this is
how she's described in the talmud and
why why is Prophet Muhammad peace and
blessing be upon him why is he honoring
why is he if he's trying to win favor
with those people at that time there why
is he honoring Jewish woman why would he
do that why yeah why would he deny the
crucifixion that's the thing it's like
if he's okay he's a Jews and Christians
they both believe Jesus was crucified so
why is he making this why is he creating
an unnecessary roadblock to conversion
by saying Jesus wasn't crucified the
reason why he's saying Jesus wasn't
crucified is because it is historically
a fact that Jesus wasn't crucified
that's why he's saying it it's a fact
and we can get into some of the evidence
of that maybe in a later show but he's
not trying to benefit himself here he's
just stating a fact because he's
receiving W right so Zionism Zionism is
total kuur I mean if you look at like uh
the spearhead of the um of the
Protestant movement Martin Luther right
Martin Luther the the famous Protestant
reformer he wrote a book called on the
Jews and their lies right and this was
something he wrote later in his life
this is not something he wrote when he
was younger and then he went back and
thought about it well maybe I shouldn't
say this this is one of the last things
he wrote you will be shocked to your
core what he says about the Jews I mean
talk about anti-Semitism this is
absolutely remarkable it's it's it's so
disgusting what do you say of someone
right now they're like okay this guy you
know you brought on this anti-semite now
have you because you're bringing these
things up you're criticizing here and
you're bringing some things as part of
teachings are you one of those
anti-semite how do you address that uh I
well the interesting thing is somebody
actually said to me I think you're an
anti-semite and I said you know the the
most beloved human being who in in the
entire universe to me was a Semite the
most beloved human beings to me plural
you know uh 100 you know some odd uh
thousand
124,000 many of them were semites uh
because the Arabs are also semites so
the fact that they're excluding the
Arabs who are the majority of the
semites from the term anti-semite is in
and of itself
anti-semitic why don't you include Arabs
because you're an anti-semite
maybe good point good point so just to
close on this this go ahead finish what
were we gonna say yeah I was going to
say I I learned Hebrew uh because uh
Judaism to me traditional Judaism is a
beautiful religion I think it's it's a
spiritual religion I think there's has a
lot of in common with with Islam I have
uh Jewish um uh colleagues that I learn
from that I benefit from that I highly
respect so this is just it's a red
herring you know you're an
anti-semite it's completely ridiculous
you know but yeah just to finish uh this
the section here on Christian Zionism
just the conclusion of ZM Zionism is
kufur according to the New Testament
right it's that means so that's
blasphemy it's total blasphemy it's
total blasphemy maybe I'll just give you
one more here in the Gospel of John you
know Jesus is having this debate uh with
the with the Jews it says it doesn't
even say scribes and Pharisees anymore
you know John is just you know he's
they're they're Jews right uh and he
says to them if you were Abraham's seed
you would do the works of Abraham and
then he says no you're not the children
of Abraham you're children of your
father the devil right so that that's
the New Testament Jesus that's not the
Quran that's not the Hadith this is the
teaching of the New Testament okay okay
the author of John says that Jesus said
this who to Jews who believed in him
they believed in him somehow but not all
the way right maybe they didn't believe
that he was divine or something so the
New Testament Jesus the Johann and Jesus
says you're Children Of Satan and then
in Romans 6 this is a really important
one Romans chapter 6 and Hebrews chapter
10 okay Paul says that Jesus's sacrifice
for sin was the be all and all sacrifice
okay so according to the New Testament
Jesus is the ultimate Temple he is the
ultimate high priest and he's the
ultimate sacrifice this is New Testament
Christianity yet Christian zionists
fully support the Third Temple okay
where sin sacrifices will return one day
according to Jewish messianism how can
followers of the New Testament Jesus and
Paul of Tarsus support this and call
themselves Bible believing Christians it
doesn't make any sense again Christian
Zionist in Oxy it's like saying
Open Secret original copy Living Dead
doesn't make any sense so we'll close on
this one here so this is for the first
1800 years of Christian history
Christian had no concept of this
pre-tribulation this Rapture this whole
thing now that's coming uh that's become
popular and then the pastor um that I
that I interviewed and then you had the
James the Dr James White and many are
coming who out who are who also were
programmed with this but it's linked to
this SC this con artist Scofield
and then um I believe in the story that
the pastor is telling me he was funded
by a Zionist attorney and this zus
attorney invited him to this Lotus Club
in New York he was it was something that
was very expensive only invite only and
then they flew him out to UK to the
Oxford uh Oxford uh uh publishing they
got him a book deal and they pushed a
million of these copies for free he was
telling me for free into the colleges
into the church into the churches and
then it kicked off even more with um uh
books like um it was a book it kind of
di it didn't really go much anywhere but
then there was this book in 1970s uh
hail Lindsay uh the the late great
planet Earth have you heard of this book
it sold 40 million copies and then they
had a series on this it was like uh sold
a video series that sold like 80 million
copies and it and it pushed this whole
thing end of time prophecies the
tribulation so what we're getting from
you what we're getting from the pastors
and other uh academics that this is like
you said an oxymoron this is something
that was pushed in dis sky from this con
artist the scoffield B reference Bible
and this is totally against Christianity
and is not biblical at all at all yeah
Zionism is a contradiction because the
reason this is so important because I
can see Christians who preach Jesus the
prince of peace we love Jesus we we
believe he was a man of Peace we love
him you can't be a Muslim unless you
love and rever as a mighty messenger and
now they're probably torn within their
hearts they're seeing these children
they're being massacred a genocide but
they think it's part of their Creed now
they think it's sinful to reject to
something and so it's an internal
struggle so hopefully when they see this
oh they can breathe and say now they can
speak up and condemn this because it's
not Blasphemous to actually Blas it's
total Blasphemous yeah so we're actually
helping the Christians here big time man
to to to go with their heart to go with
uh Humanity this is a human thing now
yeah exactly on the right side of
History be on the right side exactly
exactly yeah now let's get into some of
this um this stuff here so I want to
preface by saying that um after after
911 for those of us that remember a
group of really anti-muslim sort of
warmongering propagates kind of emerged
in the public discourse and they were
they were actually paid handsomely by
these neocon think tanks so what they
would do is they would quote the Quran
there's a verse in the Quran in
particular which is called ayat safe
although the word safe s does not appear
anywhere in the Quran but this verse is
called ayat of sa is chapter 9 verse 5
of the Quran so these propagates they
try to convince the American people and
the entire West by extension uh that
Muslims believe in unmitigated Perpetual
Warfare against unbelievers the Quran
orders all Muslims to kill every
non-muslim on the planet man woman and
child because the Quran says kill the
idolators wherever you find them in that
verse and if Muslims deny this they're
just lying this called Tak right
credential concealment and there were
popular TV shows like 2003 2004 2005
trying to justify a war right these
popular TV shows where they would depict
you know the seemingly normal and
peaceful Muslim family next door who
were really just terrorists you know
this is absolutely despicable uh and and
this is how these so-called wars of
terror against Muslims were Justified
for the Western public uh I mean some
4.7 million Muslims have been killed in
these wars of terror in the last 20
years in Afghanistan
in Iraq in Syria so this is just based
on the LIE it's a blood Lial and the
Jewish people they understand well the
power of a blood Lial so in medieval
Europe okay check this out in medieval
Europe the Christians made up the
infamous lie that Jews kidnap and kill
Christian children and use their blood
for Magical rituals and in the making of
the unleavened Passover bread h people
can look this up look up William of
Norwich Simon of Trent right some of
these children were even canonized by
the Catholic church this was a common
liable in England in France in Spain in
Germany this lie contributed to massive
persecution of European jewry I mean
Edward I first eventually ex exiled the
entire population Jewish population uh
uh from England in in 1290 but it was
all a lie you know it's like saying you
know they say Muslims Muslims decapitate
innocent babies this is a total blood
Lial but back to ayat to I just want to
touch on this yes when we look at the
context of this verse in the Quran right
so I tell I tell the students I say the
the first three rules of T right of
quranic EX Jesus is uh is context the
second rule is context and the third
rule is context right just like they say
the the first three rules of real estate
are location location location so when
we look at this verse in the Quran it's
plain and obvious meaning it's very
clear that the Quran is referring to
Pagan Arabs in the hijaz in the Arabian
Peninsula Who broke their treaty with
the Muslims they were given four months
to leave or face retaliation from the
Muslims and the Quran goes to say if at
any time a mushrik asks for Asylum from
the Muslims he must be granted Asylum
this is according to the passage inah
Toba take him to a place of safety
recite the Quran to him and if he refus
loses Islam then take him to the border
and release him so so 95 has a Locka of
condition it it's it's tied to a a place
it applies to the hijaz the heartland of
Islam right the cities of Mecca and
Medina there can be no outward idolatry
in these places okay so no killing of
the innocent is mentioned no killing of
women and children is ever mentioned no
destroying buildings and livestock and
infrastructure and if a handful of
Muslim ignorant Muslim extremist invoke
this verse as a justification for the
killing of civilians then they stand
condemned right these are called These
are extremists they have to twist and
turn the Quran and Sunnah to coincide
with their deviant right show show me
where the Prophet himself sallallahu
alaihi wasallam ordered the killing of
women and children nowhere now there is
a war policy mentioned and explicitly
described in the Tanakh several times
it's called people should know this word
h e r e m h e r
m it's actually related to the word
haram in Arabic and it translates what's
it mean so I'll get to the the
definitions right here so where is this
mentioned it's mentioned in Exodus
Deuteronomy Joshua 1 Samuel it's all
over the place okay so the definition
according to academic sources so the
Strong's Concordance okay it says to ban
devote destroy utterly completely
destroy dedicate for Destruction
exterminate exterminate that's the
strongest concordance now the Lexicon
that is used in Western seminaries is
called the bdb the brown driver Briggs
Hebrew and English lexicon this is the
what I used when I was a graduate
student the bdb Lexicon and this is how
it defines Kim to exterminate the
massacre of all
inhabitants okay then you have ginius
Gus's Hebrew CDI lexicon was used before
the bdb to exate which means to
eradicate to destroy utterly so what's
an example ofm in the Bible Well we go
to Deuteronomy chapter 20: 16
Deuteronomy
20116 so here God is telling Moses and
the cities that God gave to the
Israelites as an inheritance right the
promised land that all living things of
these cities all living things must be
exterminated okay in the very words of
the text it says
in Hebrew you shall save nothing alive
that
breathes and it goes on to say you shall
utterly destroy the Hittites the
amorites the Canaanites the perizzites
the hivites the jebusites as the Lord
thy God has commanded thee thee so this
is total extermination explicitly
ordered by the text genocide explicitly
ordered by the text and it's plain and
obvious meaning you don't have to twist
and turn it this is what it says on the
surface so I mentioned the
conquest did I mention I didn't mention
the conquest of Mecca the conquest the
prophet Muhammad sallallahu alaihi
wasallam he came into meca he declared a
general amnesty he was well within his
rights to punish the entire city so is
it true that you cannot find one text
now in the Quran or the statements
authentic statements of prophet Muhammad
where he's talking about harming
innocent children innocent
civilians no nothing like this there's
nothing in our tradition this is this is
considered to be according to to this is
multiply attested women and children
civilians they're never targeted this is
absolutely go with what you're saying it
goes back to okay we're saying that but
can we give a live example yeah so the
conquest of mea no I'm talking about
before you go there because with the
rabbi because can we give a live can I
show a video that you can actually yes
can I show a couple here okay the point
is right here that hasem say do not have
mercy on the children kill all their
children also why there no difference
between them and their children in 10
years from now these children will
attack you on the way a knows God knows
you kill all men and all
women even babies who
breastfeed
amazing all axes all goats camels
donkeys don't leave anything any memory
from this filthy
Nation so that's what the Torah say
someone is on the way to kill you now or
in a year from now you can kill him even
now a year before you don't have to wait
a minute before you know this person
will kill you statistically that's what
it always constantly repeat so you're
allowed to go and attack him first is to
remember to erase the nation of Amal the
memory of them even not only physically
to erase them from the face of the Earth
anything that remind us about them is
Mitzvah to dismiss and to erase it from
the face of the Earth we assume
that is the Germans after we see what
they did in Holocaust not only to the
Jews to the whole
world and it's not only the Germans it's
most of the European countries that's
where Amal have you heard of the thing
Commandments of War well let me tell you
what it's all about but I want you to
listen to it and compare it to the other
side and you'll see who we truly are and
that's why you should be proud of
yourself this what prophet Muhammad
sallallahu alaihi wasallam and his
successors after him when they sent an
army here's the instructions
do not kill a child do not kill a woman
do not kill an old man do not kill an
animal unless suffices your hunger do
not cut a tree down do not burn their
homes do not pollute their water do not
invade them at night when he was asked
why he says he may not wake that
nurseing child and the mother and you
will find those who devoted themselves
to worship God in their own ways leave
them to worship God in their own ways
fight only those who fight you now
you'll understand why you should be
raising your head up high and proud to
be a Muslim not the other side do the
exact opposite and justifying it for
whatever means they have they make out
off the water from us but we give them
the water they make out of the food but
we give them food what they take down is
just the rubbles that will touch the
ground but our Spirits is linked to the
heavens and that's the
truth disturbing are we is this is this
how do we understand I mean this is It's
really um just listening to it just
gives you kind of uh it's creepy you
know what I mean mean because we are
always we are always I can imagine if an
Imam came out and was saying No Mercy
nothing and the media would just run
with this and they would like you know
it'd be it'd be something all over the
place and why don't they call out people
like this this element here that's pre
preaching and teaching this now no
mercy everyone get them all children and
animals and I mean you know even why not
the human rights uh okay if you want you
don't want the human rights so what
about the animal rights organization
even talking about eliminating the you
know
animals yeah I don't who was it voltera
rouso one of these guys he said if you
want to know who really rules over your
Society determine Those whom you're not
allowed to criticize you know so our our
our media seems to be controlled by
zionists so you know if something's on
the news cycle I mean you can just
imagine if a Muslim had said something
like this you know there there's this
guy the rabbi on YouTube his name is
Manis fredman he has like 400,000
followers he's very very popular and
he's he he says things like this all the
time he says the same thing but hold on
I would think like we're coming out
we're we would condemn any any uh
extreme ideology or any Fringe element
of Islam will come out but now are there
there RIS who will come out that we can
work with to say hold on to come this
that's a good point yeah I'm gonna get
I'm gonna talk about that now these
passages how are they actually dealt
with by rabbis but just to give you an
example of what um the one of the rabbis
that you played what was he talking
about so this is in Joshua 6: 21 right
so this called the conquest of Jericho
so I was going to make the comparison
between the conquest of Mecca by the
prophet Muhammad sallallahu alaihi
wasallam where he
said there's no blemish on you today
right today is a day of
Mercy this is the day that God exalts
you're right now for the people who
never heard this what right now you're
you're you're narrating when Prophet
Muhammad what he came in after being
what how many years tortured his whole
followers persecuted uh you know
horrendous crimes were committed to them
20 years 20 so he had a he had a chance
to inflict Revenge now and he's fully
within his rights to to take to punish
the entire city and he and he forgave
the entire city th this is a conquest of
Mecca but what does the Bible say about
the conquest of Jericho so let's look at
it it says right here it
says
so this is a verb this comes from the
verb the word so it's the verb the
verbal form is used it means to utterly
destroyed and they the Israelites
utterly destroyed exterminated
everything that was in the city it
says man and
woman young and old it goes on to say
the old the ox the Sheep the
donkey all by the edge of the sword all
by the edge of can you can you imagine
this can you imagine impaling women
impaling children with swords and Spears
toddlers babies you know this is called
you know here's the point the wholesale
Slaughter of innocent civilians as a
policy of war is sanctioned by Jewish
and Christian texts Deuteronomy 20
Joshua 6 1st Samuel 15 these are Jewish
and Christian texts the Christians can't
say these are not Christian texts that's
the Old Testament no it's it's it's the
Christian Bible so Christians they want
to sort of sometimes associate
themselves from the Old Testament there
was a Christian in the late 1 Century
early 2 Century he was a gnostic his
name was marcian of cop he actually said
I can't I can't reconcile the New
Testament with the Old Testament so it
must be a different God there must be
two gods do you think now many of these
Christian politicians and others are out
there now who are standing by while we
have all these innocent genocides taking
place they should actually if they're
chrisan go back and tell the extreme
Zionist that hold on you guys this is to
convince them that this is actually
something that's uh old part of the law
they should try to persuade them to
leave off this to come back towards the
mercy of Jesus and whatnot yeah yeah
well just to follow the tra the the the
traditional opinion so what is the
normative Jewish opinion the traditional
opinion about these passages okay and
there and there's a there's a book uh i'
recommend here by Philip Jenkins
Professor Philip Jenkins it's called
laying down the sword why we can't
ignore the Bible's violent verses
okay so that that's a very good book and
I'll just give a quick quote from him he
says people looked at the Quran and said
Muslims have all these terrible violent
passages in their book if you actually
look in the Bible you'll find a lot of
passages and a lot of verses that are
just as violent and in some cases more
so so how do modern rabinal authorities
deal with these passages yes please tell
us so so in the Torah from Genesis to
Deuteronomy okay there are 613 mitz vote
these are called mitzvot means
Commandments okay um uh from Genesis to
Deuteronomy so the first Mitzvah the
first commandment is to marry and
produce children Genesis 1 128 okay so
the Mitzvah to commitm in the Holy Land
to exterminate the people in the holy
land this is one of the 613 in the Torah
it's number 528 as you mentioned earlier
according to the numbering of my
modities right it says leave none alive
of the Seven Nations so this is taken
directly from Deuteronomy 26 16 that I
quoted earlier okay who are these Seven
Nations well they're mentioned the
Canaanites the perizzites the hivites
ETC right now Abraham Ben Ezra who is an
imminent uh Jewish
Authority and Rabbi Hezekiah Ben Manoa
and many many others they maintained and
this is the mainstream opinion that this
Mitzvah was limited only to the
generation of Moses okay so you know
they're not going to say that these are
you know these are Fabrications to the T
text we know that the Torah has been
fabricated the Quran talks
about right alterations that were made
to the text but these are traditional
rabbis so they're going to deal with the
text so they're you can see that they're
bothered by this text so what do they
say what became the sort of traditional
uh um understanding they said that this
commandment was limited to the
generation of Moses okay that generation
that he's addressing the period during
which the Israelites will be engaged in
fighting the Canaanites in order to
settle in the land promised by God to
their ancestors if members of these
tribes had immigrated voluntarily or at
some future date returned individually
and even wish to convert to Judaism then
this is acceptable soim of these Seven
Nations was only for that time at that
place and never again and the reason is
because these groups are gone they no
longer exist so while the 613
Commandments are believed to be
perennial and Perpetual right or
transhistorical there is simply no
application of this mid
because these groups are gone okay my
mon says my Mones he says even if
descendants of these groups remain unto
today they're mixed among these other
nations so you know as long as their
evil culture has gone their idolatry
their child sacrifice their immorality
then the Mitzvah stands fulfilled and
there's no application so this is
traditional Judaism okay now it is
important to mention that no critical
Scholars or historians the Bible none of
them believe that this massive
extermination of these nations actually
ever really took place okay these
stories are exaggerations they they're
really intended probably as Scare
Tactics they function to scare the
enemies of Israel so what actually
happened to these groups you know they
migrated they assimilated many of them
converted yeah there was Wars and
battles but this kind of wholesale
genocide narrative probably didn't
happen historically okay and
interestingly we don't believe that God
would order such a thing and there's no
historical evidence would you say in
your expert opinion because we know
there's a verse in the Quran where God
Almighty Allah is saying woe to those
who write the books with their hands we
know the pre this is referring to
previous scriptures being altered and
changed would you say because Allah God
Almighty is the all loving the most
merciful the most just that this is an
example of the changing of the scripture
at that time yeah yeah I would I would
that would be my opinion yeah I've asked
many also different students and
knowledge scholar they're saying the
same thing you're saying yeah and there
there are certain laws in the Torah that
are just absolutely I mean I don't see
the wisdom behind them they they seem
very very violent can it be if you make
an example like today if you take
situation with these type of people
these Zionist type these nationalistic
type these these Supremacy type at that
time same people now they're changing
the text to go ahead and justify for
them to do what they wanted to do to
annihilate certain people yeah
interestingly the the Old Testament
itself ad mits that the Torah has
changed I mean Jeremiah in chapter 8:8
you know one of his condemnations is why
why do we why do you say that you have
the law of the Lord the Torah Adonai for
verily the false pen of the scribes have
turned it into a lie yes that's what it
says you know that's a verse right there
that is admitting that the scribes
change the text yeah exactly so there's
no evidence of these things happening
historically but what matters is belief
right and the Orthodox take these
stories literally and believe them to be
historically true as did the most
eminent Christian Scholars uh from
Augustine of Hippo to Thomas aquinus to
John Calvin okay uh there's another book
recommendation by a Christian Hoff
reader it's called making sense of Old
Testament genocide Christian
interpretations ofm passages this is
published by Oxford in 2018 where he
actually gives a survey like which
Christians believed that these things
actually happened historically God
ordered this to happen and yeah someone
like origin of Alexandria thought these
Kenan passages were figurative but he
was certainly not among the majority in
fact he was anati uh posthumously at the
second Council of Constantinople in in
553 the Common Era now the trend
nowadays from some Christian apologist
is just to deny these things and say oh
that was you know hyperbolic you know I
actually heard this recently on Catholic
radio you know this is hyperbolic you
why this trend well it's probably
because they're embarrassed in light of
what's happening right now in in Gaza
they're just embarrassed that this is
this is clearly the teachings of of the
Torah uh and clearly these are very very
disturbing and not only that again
there's no historical evidence of these
things so morally and historically these
stories these Commandments are simply
indefensible okay so that's a
traditional opinion that was for that
time and that's it okay now another
another opinion says that Kim this
extermination will happen again in the
Holy Land one more time
but only when the Messiah comes so we
have to wait for the Messiah right their
Messiah they call him
Mia the king Messiah or the uh the
davidic king Messiah so only the Messiah
can begin this process of regathering
the Jews from diaspora right and then he
will fight the uh Wars of the Lord these
are called Milat Adonai right so that's
that's another opinion now the third
opinion is the position of religious
Zionism okay in Hebrew religious Zionism
is
called the so the religious zionists
they see no contradiction between
Zionism in Orthodox Judaism traditional
Judaism now there has been a consistent
and sustained sentiment among the
religious zionists of Israel that the
Palestinians are the modern-day
Canaanites okay so this is a very common
sentiment among the religious zionists
therefore it is a religious duty of the
government of Israel to wage a war of
extermination against the Palestinian
people and this is what we're seeing
right now in all of its horror this is
radical Judaism so I encourage people to
look up you know gush emunim the
Coalition of the faithful the first
Rabbi Chief Rabbi of of Palestine
Abraham cook and his son Yehuda cook
Rabbi schlomo ainer in the minds of
these religious zionists the Israeli
government has a religious duty to
implement Mitzvah number 528 wow in
utter destroy the Palestinians they
believe that the coming of their Messiah
can be hastened through continued
aggression conquest and and and
settlement of Palestinian territories
all of this aggression will culminate in
the coming of their Messiah and guess
what the political party known as halud
are are uh extremely dedicated religious
zionists of course lud's chairman is
Netanyahu uh who has been the prime
minister of Israel since 2009 so he's
surrounded by these radical Jews right
so they believe that they can use
divinely sanctioned violence to
essentially prepare the land for the
Messiah they can get the ball moving
right uh before his arrival they can
start the process and the Messiah will
will finish it and again we see that the
plain and obvious policy that the
Israeli government as a whole is
applying to the Palestinians in Gaza and
now the West Bank because they want the
Temple Mount this this policy cannot be
described as anything other thanm it ISM
in 202
they are preparing the land for their
Messiah they are offering their King a
massive Human Sacrifice that's what um
Philip Jenkins calls it it is a massive
Human Sacrifice so Palestinian civilians
are paying for the sins of Europe
Professor Ros seagull s g- l he's a
professor at Stockton University he's an
Israeli journalist Ross seagull is an
Israeli journalist right he's Israeli he
specializes this is his specialty
Holocaust and genocide studies okay he
says he's an expert he says what Israel
is doing right now to the Palestinians
is quote a textbook case of genocide
textbook genocide this is a Israeli
academic Professor Rod seagull R seagull
yeah seagull Holocaust and genocide
studies expert textbook genocide
textbook genocide and he cites he cites
the un's definition of genocide and Elon
Pape he calls it incremental genocide
again these are Israeli journalists
Israeli historians right here here's a
quote from the defense minister of
Israel yoan yoav Galant this the current
defense minister of Israel he said this
on October 9th this is a quote I have
ordered a Complete Siege on the Gau of
the strip no electricity no food no fuel
everything is closed we're fighting
Human animals and we will act
accordingly we will exterminate we will
eliminate everything so this is called
we have to get to know this word and
educate people about this word you know
as you said we've heard Jihad Jihad
Jihad ad
why haven't we heard
of you know uh Elon Pape said recently
just recently I think the other day he
gave an interview he said every 10
minutes a Palestinian child is murdered
every 10 minutes how many children have
been killed since we started this
podcast you know it's amazing you know
how is it that in 2004 my non-muslim
neighbor is asking me he's grilling me
what's Jihad
what's right but in 2023 when there's an
actual genocide happening
right we have no idea what is what is am
we're going to talk about Amal too te
tea would be something like if you
believe what this Rabbi does and now to
win over a friendship with this is part
of your Creed you believe uh deny Jesus
and say the most horrible things about
his mother and someone asked you about
that and you're just like you're hiding
that that'll be teia but we don't have
this such thing now yes there are places
like if your your wife cooks you a bad
meal or something but to deceive people
to bring people into the religion this
is something I when I spoke to many
scholars said toia this is a shi concept
this term is not in the Quran and Sunnah
this is something that a sect of shii
because they'll push this out there and
now how are you going to sit with your
Muslim neighbor friend when they program
in your mind that he's deceitful he's
lying but isn't this something that is
in the Bible with Paul also when he's
like to a Jew I'm a Jew to a gentile
Gentile all things to all men yeah
exactly a form of what's the verse he
said um if my Lie by my lie I'm able to
propagate the truth I'm paraphrasing the
the verse why Mye why judge the CER yeah
exactly yeah yeah
that's that's on us but we don't do teia
very good exactly we we don't have you
know we don't we don't believe in
indiscriminate wholesale Slaughter of
civilians but it's in their text and now
they can they can interpret it however
they want but it's in the text we don't
have it in our text yeah so yeah I think
it's time to push back a little I think
it's time for us to demand answers you
we're constantly in this defensive
position MH we have to expose a double
standard in a more robust way the
present policy cannot be the new normal
we have to call a spade a spade right
because what's happening to the
Palestinians right now is nothing less
than terrorism Zionism as deployed by
Israel is radical Judaism right and
people shouldn't forget that the
persecution of the Palestinians uh at
the hands of radical Jewish elements it
goes back to 1917 and this way before
October 7th yeah what's the San
hendrum the Sanhedrin yeah uh yeah
because um the reason I bring that up is
uh and then you can go into your next uh
which you're going to explain but it I
want to put frame this in the context of
Christians living under um when Muslims
ruled Jerusalem even Jews historically
they were taken care of in the Sharia
their rights were guarded but it just
seems like a really strange relationship
where you have Christians who who are
who are there and they had they they had
journalists who were dressed up as as
Christian priests and in in the first
five minutes they were spit on I think
like five times recently Israeli Channel
13 reporter Yosi Ellie went undercover
as a priest for a day dressed in a robe
he walked through the old city with
Franciscan father Alberto in the first
five minutes he was spat at five times
by Orthodox Jewish Israelis so you got
the spitting of Christian the disrespect
and and this clip here I'll show you
here that he mentioned this I respect
you doesn't have to respect you doesn't
have to respect
that is the right thing are you Jewish
do you want to honor
God that is The Godly thing to do we
respect one other The Godly thing to do
is to kill you The Godly thing is to
kill me that's right that's what the
Torah says the Torah says to kill us the
Torah says that I don't people who
worship Idol such as yourself when there
is a
Sanhedrin to kill us yes okay that's
what the T so we know how the Jewish
people feel about Christians yes that
you discriminate against Christians
Christians are Idol wor
the Torah says that Christianity is idol
worship Muslims would protect the
Christians rights we wouldn't be now if
we're majority because many Christians
think that we just like he's saying
that's it but actually he's saying it is
he one of those extreme zionists here
who's hijacked the Judaism because he's
telling this Christian that if the San
hendrum what's the San hendrum if it
comes San hendin is the high religious
Court of the Jews so he's saying that
basically when the the Third Temple is
built because the San hen is connected
to the whole pries apparatus and the
temple and all of that so in other words
when they seize control the entire land
they're going to exterminate so he's
he's he's taking like the second opinion
right we said basically that when the
Messiah comes and the temple is built
right and the and the priesthood the
kohanim they come back we have our
Sanhedrin our it's called the the
Council of the elders and we're going to
take you guys out this is what what a
strange relationship and they're funding
this they're funding their own uh
strange day this is really strange
really really strange yeah that's true
no I mean yeah so the the special intent
on genocide is on Full display uh when
you listen to these Israeli politicians
Military Officers here's a quote from an
IDF official spokesperson Daniel hagari
he said quote the emphasis is on damage
not on accuracy the emphasis is on
damage right so is this is defensive
this is minimalizing you know collateral
damage no the intention is to maximize
collateral damage he actually admits it
the former Israeli Prime Minister
Neftali Bennett he was asked about pales
inian babies in hospital incubators who
need electricity to survive this is a
quote from him Are you seriously talking
about Palestinian babies we fighting
Nazis I'm not feeding electricity or
water to my enemies wow yes I've heard
this yes then you have un officials
they're they have you know this is on
their conscience a lot of them are
resigning Craig mckyer a a the former
director of the New York office of the
United Nations High Commissioner for
human rights he just resigned recently
this is what he said this is a direct
quote from Craig mckyer m o k h i b r
Craig mcber he said quote the wholesale
Slaughter the whole the current
wholesale Slaughter of the Palestinian
people rooted in an ethnonationalist
Colonial Colonial settler ideology in
continu in continuation of Decades of
their systematic persecution and purging
based upon entirely upon their status as
Arabs and coupled with explicit
statements of intent intent by by
leaders in the Israeli government and
military leaves no room for doubt no
room for doubt that it's what that it's
a genocide he continues what's more the
governments United States United Kingdom
and much of Europe are wholly complicit
in the horrific assault okay this is
some scary stuff I mean listening to
this it seems like everything that's
been projected on Muslims If people
really opened their heart and their
minds and they studied you know Islam
really they would really now in compar
it to this now you can really see why we
say that Prophet Muhammad was sent as a
Mercy For All Mankind indeed Islam is a
mercy and because you can't what else
when you see this actually this
wholesale Slaughter of uh children right
now in front of your eyes and people are
just asleep to it and they're they're
they're not we often heard this for
you've heard this your whole life never
again never again I'm asking does this
include
Palestinians yeah the whole concept of
never again never to that's supposed to
be to us now and living in the modern
age to never allow a genocide you know a
holocaust of a people right now we're
seeing a holocaust happening to the
Palestinians right there who are also
Christians Muslims and 10% I believe are
Christian yeah and what's interesting is
that uh is that modern anti-zionist
activists have been recently citing
studies that demonstrate that that that
Palestinians lentine Arabs but in
including Palestinians they actually
have genetic continuity with the ancient
Canaanites right in other words uh
they're descendants of the Canaanites so
so why are ancient why are anti- Zionist
highlighting these studies this all
relates to the debate about the land who
was there first right so like a Zionist
would say there's there's a Zionist I
read a tweet from him he said the word
Jew comes from Judea the word Arab comes
from Arabia so who's occupying whose
land right and another words the Jews
were there first right but these recent
studies are being cited to show that
Palestinians are actually descendants of
the ancient Canaanites who were there
before the Israelites even Philip
Jenkins in his book says it's without
doubt that the Palestinians are
descendants of Cana
but we can only imagine how this
argument can actually
embolden the religious zionists of
Israel can you imagine you see they
admit they are Canaanites and it's our
duty to wipe them out according to
Mitzvah number 528 now there are two
more mitzvot and we'll I'll finish with
this inshallah there are two more mitz
two more Commandments that deserve our
immediate and undivided attention so
Mitzvah number 604 it says cut off the
seed of AMC okay that is destroy them
utterly commit against AMC and uh
commandment number 605 the very next one
mitsa number 605 um that says blot out
the memory of Amal and don't forget Amal
so both of these are taken from
Deuteronomy
25:19 extremist Messianic Israeli
settlers they often invoke AMC as a
justification for the massacre and
displacement of the Palestinian people
so who is AMC so AMC are also called the
amalekites so in 1st Samuel 15 King Saul
was ordered by God to commit against the
amalekites to exterminate men women and
child and animals total extermination
now King Saul however he spared the
amalekite king AAG okay now in Esther
chapter 3 The Book of Esther we're told
that Haman a Persian minister of Xerxes
was an agagite in other words he was a
descendant of AAG in other words he was
an amalekite and Haman wanted to exter
terminate the Jews so this is sort of
the mo of the amalekites they want to
destroy Israel now the Torah says in the
Hebrew it
says the Lord will be at war against
Amal from generation to generation M
door means Perpetual Warfare again you
know how they had this idea Muslims
believe In Perpetual Warfare unmitigated
Perpetual Warfare against unbelievers
they want to conquer the planet it's
right the Lord will be at war against
AMC from generation to generation the
Lord declares Perpetual Warfare against
amalec so now how do traditional Jews
okay uh interpret these Commandments
against AMC they interpret them on
Strictly genealogical grounds uh usually
in other words any and all descendants
of amalec must be killed irrespective of
their culture right uh this is why when
it comes to the Seven Nations like the
Canaanites right you can convert to
become a Ben Noah you could follow the
seven noahic laws or you could convert
to Judaism but there's actually a
difference of opinion about the
amalekites the conversion of an
amalekite okay whether he should be
allowed to convert or not if not he
should be killed however many would
argue since it's also impossible to
identify who is an amalekite this
commandment again simply cannot be
fulfilled okay uh so like my Mones he he
he will further limit the application to
destroy AMC to a Jewish King he says
only like an anointed Jewish King can
carry out the Mitzvah he probably means
the Messiah so if there's no Messiah you
can't really do this right um so that's
that's traditional Judaism however
common among Jewish zionists is this
horrible and disturbing teaching that
the term Amal can refer to any enemy of
the Jew so they so they're going against
their greatest scholar also mcmanes no
oh yeah oh yeah completely yeah so so
this has now become the mindset of Amal
the mentality of AMC right the culture
of continues perpetually so you know
they're looking back at history the
Romans were the AMC of their day the
Nazis were the amalec right so what does
what does that mean they have to find an
AMC in every generation they have to
find an AMC there was a Jewish professor
at UCLA she was a Zionist um Deborah
litat who famously referred to a British
historian of German history uh David
Irving she called him quote temporary
AMC what does that mean he deserves to
be killed for his views on History this
is a dog whistle in other words it it
contains a message that only a few
people can understand now guess upon
whom modern zionists apply this Den
designation more than any other now
broadly speaking anyone who argues for
the dissolution of the modern state of
Israel or challenges the legality of
this you know this modern nationalistic
apari it's apari according to Nelson
Mandela Desmond Tutu you know Jimmy
Carter uh but Iran has been called you
know AMC uh but here's another quote
from uh from the director of land
Authority his name was benzy Lieberman
right director of Israeli land Authority
he said this in 2004 actually okay he
said uh and you know these are people in
positions of power he's the director
he's not like some nobody these are
people making decisions he said quote
the Palestinians are AMC we will destroy
them that's that's a direct quote now
you understand what that means he's
invoking genocide of the Palestinian
people and so this goes back um to plit
in
1947 so you know these are religious
extremists drunk on Messianic fervor
right I mean they're they're trying to
inaugurate their Messianic age with a
massive Human Sacrifice um but you know
I mentioned this earlier too um in
another podcast I truly believe that
Jewish people that are good and
compassionate when the real Messiah
comes when
isaam when he comes back I think that
these people will will accept him as as
the Messiah right um you know how do you
how do how do how do uh many of your
colleagues who are Jewish uh when you
share some of these things with them how
do they take to it no they they agree
with me completely you know um of course
you have uh different opinions and
things like that but the people that I
interact with you know they the
important thing is that we can talk
about these things in in a civil way and
let people know because knowledge is
power yes you know we have to talk about
the these are realities you know you
know what's crazy on October 27th uh I I
mentioned AMC I mentioned a few of these
things the very next day Netanyahu
himself maybe you have the clip of
Netanyahu what he said about amet and
and Netanyahu actually you know he a few
years ago he blamed the Holocaust on the
Palestinians I mean I mean he his claim
is that Hitler just wanted to Exile them
right but when Hitler met the Muti uh am
Al Hussein
Al husseini the grand muy of of
Palestine it was the Grand Muti of
Palestine Who convinced Hitler to
exterminate the Jews right I mean Norman
Normal Norman finlin a jewi a Jewish
finish thought I was gonna say finlin
Norman finlin who's a Jewish
intellectual whose parents were murdered
at aitz yes he said he said this claim
of Netanyahu that the Palestinians it
was the Palestinians idea to commit the
Holocaust is beyond lunacy right it's
just
he's completely lost his mind this guyah
but go ahead play the clip you must
remember what Amal has done to you says
our Holy Bible and we do remember and we
are fighting our brave troops and
combatants who are now in Gaza or around
Gaza and in all other regions in
Israel are joining this chain of Jewish
Heroes a chain that has started 3,000
years ago from Joshua
yeah there it is and he he makes that
reference to Joshua Bon right according
to the Tanakh what did Joshua Bon do he
implemented on the upon the ancient
Canaanites he's talking about the
conquest of Jericho right the conquest
of the entire land so all through all
this that's going on right now and I've
heard also that he's an atheist he's a
secular atheist uh Netanyahu I don't
know if we can if we can confirm that
but same like Theodor herzo the prophet
who they really follow who was an
atheist you started off with he's
probably so now but they're conveniently
taking things from the Bible now to push
this genocidal agenda he's got these
radical Jewish elements in his ear uh in
in his party in his cabinet and and
they're pushing this agenda hard you
know so so what else does the Torah say
about am so 2519 Deuteronomy this is
what it sounds like in Hebrew it
says so in Arabic it's
translated you must blot out the very
mention of AMC from under the sky right
so right now in in in Western public
discourse there's this disturbing Trend
that any defense whatsoever of the
Palestinian people is being branded as
supporting terrorism and
anti-emetic why well the remembrance of
AMC The Very mention of amalec must be
blotted out and for these Zionist
extremists and zealots Palestine is
amalik and as we said earlier Western
media seems to be completely controlled
by Zionist propag Anda so now just
having a Palestinian flag is seen as
supporting terrorism and propaganda and
hating Jews right I have a Palestinian
flag that means I hate Jews it's
ridiculous people are losing their jobs
across multiple Industries for even
uttering a word of support for Palestine
for speaking out against carpet bombing
of civilians meanwhile in Palestine
what's happening Palestinian families
are debating about whether they should
all stay in one place or to split up
because if they split up and the bombs
drop at least their entire entire family
won't be killed over 900 Palestinian
families have been taken off the planet
I mean this is what Palestinians are
doing right now uh this is their
discussion as they eat dinner together I
mean Palestinian parents right now are
writing the names of their children on
their children in case they're bombed so
the parents can identify the remains of
their children this is what Palestinians
are doing right now and of course you
know the zionists they release these
fake
images fake recordings you know uh you
know God knows what they can do with the
AI it's all trickster ISM they have to
manufacture consent I encourage everyone
who's listening to this right now to to
Simply read the book of Genesis you know
read the book of Genesis okay um and uh
I mean the person of Jacob in the Book
of Genesis and this goes back to this
idea of right this this cannot be the
Torah okay and and and Muslim opinion
about the Integrity of of the modern day
Torah is totally in line with the vast
consensus uh or the total consensus of
historical Scholars regarding the penet
or the Torah and in Genesis Jacob is a
master trickster who no matter what he
does God continues to bless him he has
unconditional Divine support for his
deception and Jacob is called Israel
Jacob is Israel now this is not y this
is not the great prophet Jacob peace be
upon him this is Jacob in the Book of
Genesis okay and at the end of Genesis
even Jacob son Yousef Joseph he ends up
tricking the Egyptians he tricks them
and ends up enslaving them right this is
not in the Quran the Quran corrects
these narratives but Genesis is a
primary text in Judaism you know and as
they say one of my teachers used to say
if if such are the clergy then then God
bless the congregation right if one of
their greatest Patriarchs described in
their most sacred book who is also the
namesake of their nation is this master
deceiver what do we expect from Zionist
Israel you know the motto of mosad
Israel's National Intelligence Agency
they changed it but it used to be by
deception you may wage war that was
their whole motto right wow there that
reminds me I don't know if you've uh
read there's independent uh journalist
award-winning journalist Max Blumenthal
he has they run the gray Zone it's
article called uh it's October 7
testimonies reveal israeli's military
shelling Israeli citizens with tanks and
missiles had me think about that when
you're mentioning that have you have you
read this uh yeah have you come across
this I mean just you know people should
Google the Hannibal directive just look
up Hannibal directive wow this is a deep
one yeah Hannibal directive just just
read about the Hannibal directive and
you'll see what we're talking about as
far as deception goes wow this is really
deep yes and and the horrible aspect of
this is is that you know I have heard
that's mentioned in this article also
this Hannibal directive yes yeah yeah
it's there yes this is all this is all
true it's accurate so so for people who
don't know uh they can wash us deer but
this is pretty much that uh if you have
somebody that someone has a hostage
pretty much you can annihilate everyone
so no one gets the hostage so it's
imagine if you uh you're you're in an
auditorium with uh and and a shooter
comes in and he's got a thousand kids
hostage the Hannibal directive would
would tell you to just blow up the whole
building yeah yeah well in in Palestine
right so so I was going to mention this
that one of the horrible aspects of this
is that I've heard otherwise decent and
moral people uh defend Israel's attack
on Palestine they say this is not the
same as like like Hiroshima or Nagasaki
they'll say in Hiroshima the express
purpose was to Target civilians but in
Palestine the Israeli military they
they're saying that they don't intend to
kill civilians it just happens on
accident so it's okay civilians are
killed on accident is absolute nonsense
and how incredibly disturbing so
according to that logic Israel could uh
kill in theory one million children
right and say you know that was not Our
intention right so for these these
cowardly apologists uh for Israel my
question is when will it be enough for
you how to grow a backbone and condemn
Israel how many more children have to be
cut to Pieces how many whole families
have to be you know taken off the planet
before you grow a backbone and condemn
that Israel that admit this is clearly a
genocide you know if a Hamas fighter was
hiding in a hospital in Tel Aviv would
Israel blow up that hospital in Tel Aviv
of of course not but in Palestine right
they say yes well there was a Hamas
fighter uh and everyone was killed on
accident I mean they think we're stupid
this this is just
ridiculous is there anything else that
uh you think is very relevant to this I
just wanted I just wanted to you know
remind people of there's a beautiful Dua
I'll just you know end with this there's
a Dua of the Prophet Muhammad sallallahu
alaihi wasallam because you know
deception is everywhere the Western
media is gaslighting the world you know
the oppressors are seen as the oppressed
and vice versa so the prophet used to
pray uh so uh he said sallallah alaihi
wasallam oh Allah and we can you can if
you don't know this in Arabic we can say
it in English uh show us the truth as
truth show us the truth as truth and
give us the ability to follow it right
and show us the falsehood as falsehood
and give us the ability uh to shun it um
so you know we have these prophetic
invocations we have these these
prophetic supplications and they're the
words of the Prophet Muhammad sallallahu
alaihi wasallam he's the best of
creation and he is the leader of the
messengers so these words have they have
power to them they have to they have
Providence from Allah subhana wa tala so
take the advice um of of our Scholars
take the Commandments of the Quran you
know a lot of Muslims right now
obviously this is a very troubling time
they're in a State of Shock and Awe but
Allah
says hold on to the Rope of God that's
the Quran the prophet said hold on to
myah establish the prayer this is very
important Muslims need to pray five
times a day okay we need to do
that the difference between faith and
disbelief is leaving the prayer right so
non-muslim non-muslim uh non- praying
Muslims these are sort of lwh hanging
fruit for the for the impostor Messiah
the the we believe in impostor Messiah
and if we're not praying we don't have
that remembrance every so often we're
going to forget Allah and we're going to
follow other people and we don't want to
follow the Imposter Messiah right learn
du uh last thing I just want to touch
upon for anyone who has any doubt of the
mercy of Islam I just want to recant
this history and if you can just touch
upon it because the whole thing is the
eradication of Jews that's why they're
doing this and whatnot but if you study
history if you you gave a beautiful
example of a Muhammad but if you look at
U Omar the one the kff of Islam that
when he conquered when they came into
Jerusalem didn't he repopulate the city
with Jews and he actually the Temple
Mount was full of 500 years of garbage
and he himself got out there he actually
went to repopulate the city with Jews
actually they were exiled and he also
protected churches by not actually
praying in a church worrying that the
Christians would come the Muslims would
come later and say he prayed in the
church so to take it over so you had
these two these groups
uh they were protected because of Islam
and for hundreds of years there was
coexistence there was some kind of peace
is that true can you on he didn't
rebuild the Temple but he he honored the
the the site of the second he honored
the site yeah it was being garbage Dum
yeah and uh you know if you if you read
Jewish history they call it the pact of
Omar and it was seen as a great blessing
for uh the Jews of that region uh to
live under Shar because Muslims
recognize the Jews as monotheists of
right they're people of the book They're
people of the Revelation even the
Christians when the Muslims came into
Jerusalem the Christians were fighting
each other and they wouldn't allow
certain Christians but for the Muslims
they're allab so they so the Muslim
leaders they gave all the Christians
equal rights they didn't care who's a
monophysite and who's a trinitarian
who's a Catholic no he said you're all
so he treated them all equally right so
this is incredible history people need
to to study history um there's a lot of
demonization there's a lot of inaccurate
things out there um but um yeah I mean
Muslim Spain right the Golden Age of
Judaism you know this is a this is a
period of history that we need to
revisit and isn't there a uh many
professors that one that comes to mind
uh David Warstein and he wrote in the JC
Journal he said Islam saved the jury
Islam saved the Jewish people uh you
have so many in Bosnia where my family's
from you had a high concentration of
Jews who fled persecution you had the
Bessa you had the albanians right who
because of Islam's teaching they
protected the Jews so this whole thing
about Muslims want to radicate Jews
historically this is something that's
just a farce it's a mythology to
mythology I mean you have respected
rabbis at different periods Rabbi
Nathaniel alumi who wrote this book
called who said the prophet Muhammad
sallallahu alaihi wasallam is a ni he's
a true Prophet now he's he's not going
to go all the way and say that you know
we have to convert to Islam but he'll
say he was he was a a prophet sent to
the Gentiles because the Jews recognize
that the monotheism that the prophet
brought was unprecedented he was the
greatest monotheist who ever lived right
they recognized that I mean what he did
was more than all of their prophets put
together right just what the prophet
Muhammad sallallahu alaihi wasallam did
how successful of a monotheist he was
they recognized that there's something
special about him so some of them will
say he's a go go means that he's a he's
a muj like he's newer of of monotheism
he was a great man others say no he was
a true Prophet but he was only sent to
uh the like the non-jews the
Gentiles and others they say no he sent
to all of us and they converted to Islam
you know uh so there's there's always
been a type of mutual respect uh between
uh Jews and Muslims now this the present
conflict has skewed a lot of perceptions
and that's unfortunate so hopefully by
with a sincere heart and mind they can
come in watch what this this uh many of
these facts now that you have brought to
the to the table and hopefully good
Christians good Jews people out there
they can get unprogrammed with this
whole hijacking that's happened with the
Zionism of Christianity and Zionism of
Judaism and come back to the the way of
humanity to go ahead to um help stop
this modern day genocide that's
happening look look into the prophet
Muhammad sallallahu alaihi wasallam he
is your Prophet he's the universal
messenger
I think his his character his ethos his
s his teaching it's going to Open Hearts
people will realize the truth
in thank you so much thank you for
sharing all this with us been an honor
thank you so much thank you very
much brothers and sisters we've all had
loved ones that passed away a mother a
father a brother sister a close family
member but one of the mercies of our
Dean is that with the right intention we
can go ahead and continue to Good Deeds
on our loved ones behalf and what
greater of a continuous Good Deed Sadia
than investing on their behalf in the
deed Center a mid and meada dawa Center
that will benefit generations to come
inshallah so click the link below donate
right now may God Almighty Allah reward
all of you I cannot leave without giving
you a gift if you're not yet Muslim and
you tuneing in to see what these Muslims
are talking about and you like a free
copy of the Quran go ahead and visit
theen show.com we'll take care of the
postage and everything and get it
delivered to you and if you still have
some questions about Islam call us at 1
66247 52 we'll see you next time until
then peace be with you assalam alaykum